merci de nous retrouver sur public sénat
à suivre sur notre antenne l'audition
d'alain vidalies ce ministre délégué aux
relations avec le parlement suivie de
celle de serge lavie c'est le secrétaire
général du gouvernement
tous deux ont été entendus par la
commission sénatoriales pour
l'application des lois commission
présidée par le sénateur socialiste de
paris david assouline
objectif de cette audition faire le
bilan en matière de publication des
textes réglementaires nécessaires à une
bonne application des lois tout de suite
cette audition est bien presque bonsoir
chers collègues sur le ministre général
du gouvernement
cette cette réunion va devenir
traditionnel puisque nous avons fait la
même l'année dernière afin de faire le
point avec le secrétaire général du
gouvernement et avec le ministre des
relations avec le parlement sur le
contrôle de l'application des lois qui
est une oeuvre réalisée par l'exécutif
lui même pour optimiser sa performance
quand il pour vous puisque c'est bien
lui qui a la charge de mettre en
application des lois et pour nous
parlement notes d'exercer notre rôle de
contrôle de l'application des lois
puisque nous les produisions et en même
temps nous avions soulignées à la
constitution même de notre commission au
sénat que nous devions pallier un
problème récurrent le presque du
parlementarisme français et de son point
faible
en tous les cas qui est là la production
parfois importantes
je vais pas dire trop importantes dans
tous les cas importante de loi sans
s'attacher suffisamment aux conditions
de son application à son application
réglementaire ça va de soi mais je pense
réellement que des progrès ont été faits
ces derniers temps c'est le premier
sujet en même temps mais abordons la
problématique de façon plus globale
comme vous le savez en produisant la
loire se soucier de son application saas
et nous et ensuite qu'il y ait non
seulement le contrôle sur les missions
des règles d'application et décret etc
mais aussi de leur efficience sur le
terrain il peut y avoir des fois des
lois sans décret lé décret très
rapidement sans que les choses ne
s'applique pour différentes raisons
et là aussi nous devons contrôler alerté
le dire interpellé provoquer le débat
pour pas que les choses se fassent dans
une indifférence qui devient ensuite en
exagérant une indifférence vis-à-vis
même de la loi puisque si la loi ne
s'applique pas et bien il y a un regard
sur le travail parlementaire de la part
des citoyens qui peut devenir un regard
critique en tous les cas un regard
distant qui n'est jamais bon
comme vous le savez pour pour notre vie
démocratique donc ces quelques mots pour
donner le cadre nous allons auditionner
donc d'abord par une intervention du
ministre ensuite de secrétaire général
dans un contexte particulier par rapport
à l'année précédente
c'est qu'il y à une alternance et que
bien évidemment le contrôle de
l'application des lois pour cette année
et a changé de date pour être en
harmonie c'était une décision qu'on a
prise puisque avant vous contrôlez pas
de la même façon que le gouvernement
parce que c'est pas sur la même période
on s'entendait pas sûr sur le nombre et
les pourcentages de d'applications
puisqu'on ne on n'arrêtait pas les
compteurs en même temps la session
parlementaire précédente s'est arrêtée
octobre et on met six mois c'est ça
c'est octobre 30 septembre
c'est ce que voulait dire le 1er octobre
et comme le gouvernement je sais pas si
d'ailleurs c'est quelque chose qui est
reproduit dans vos intentions
c'était quelque chose qui avait demandé
à l'époque monsieur fillon que l'on
puisse au bout de six mois à voir
l'ensemble des décrets qui s'applique
c'était ça la date le délai qui avait
été donnée est l'objectif
notre rapport de contrôle d'application
des lois annuel sera examiné six mois
après peut pas l'être avant est donc à
peu près au mois de juin
c'est à ce moment là que nous nous
produirons notre rapport annuel sur mais
entre temps j'aimerais que vous
l'évoquiez d'une façon ou d'une autre
des lois qui ont été produites dans la
session précédente ont peut-être subi d
abrogation est donc évalué des décrets
sur les lois qui n'ont pas pu
s'appliquer ou pas eu le délai de six
mois pour s'appliquer introduira
forcément une nuance
j'espère que vous pourrez nous éclairer
sur comment comment vous faites dans ce
cas là voilà j'ai été très très bref et
en même temps trop long donc la place
surtout aux interventions et puis qui
est vraiment de la place aux questions
pour les sénateurs qui sont là je sais
qu'on est en session plénière que tout
le monde est requis pour y être parce
que il ya des votes que il faut pouvoir
assumer ces votes et c'est toujours le
problème d'avoir des commissions en même
temps que les sessions plénières saïf
c'est notre problème l'organisation je
le regrette
c'est déjà une date où la présence et
est moins forte que d'habitude il ya il
y à ça aussi mais je sais que les
sénateurs apporte attache beaucoup
d'importance à ce que nous vous faisons
là nous allons communiquer pour leur
faire connaître et vos interventions et
le compte-rendu même de nos débats de
façon importante pour qu'il puisse s'en
saisir
l'année dernière il y avait eu une
participation aussi assez importante
beaucoup de l'intervention parce que
chaque sénateur est attaché à à ce que
devient la loi à laquelle il a participé
monsieur le ministre et merci de votre
présence
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je vous remercie de cette invitation qui
est pour moi l'occasion de revenir sur
le sujet essentiel et qui est
l'application des lois
je sais que cette question a toujours
fait l'objet d'une attention très
particulière de la haute assemblée mais
la création de votre commission est une
innovation que je tiens à saluer dans
les régimes parlementaires européens le
contrôle du gouvernement est en effet
avec l'exercice du pouvoir législatif
une des deux fonctions essentielles des
assemblées au contrôle de l'application
des lois y apparaît comme un
prolongement naturel presque de
l'activité législative dans le cadre du
plf 2013 la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale a ainsi adopté à
l'unanimité un amendement présenté par
françois cornut gentille et christian
eckert pour renforcer les pouvoirs de
contrôle et de suivi du parlement dans
le cadre de la modernisation de l'action
publique
vous le savez sans doute au royaume-uni
pays pionnier en la matière
le gouvernement a l'obligation de
dresser un bilan d'application effective
des lois
une commission mixte paritaire
généralement présidée par un
parlementaire de l'opposition est chargé
d'examiner les textes d'application des
lois en prenant mes fonctions de
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement j'ai souhaité mme emparé de
cette question du suivi de l'application
des lois afin de lui donner un
traitement politique appropriée en
parfait accord avec le cabinet du
premier ministre
nous avons donc constitué un comité
interministériel de l'application des
lois dit sial que j'ai l'honneur de
présider en compagnie de monsieur serge
lasvignes secrétaire général du
gouvernement
je les fais naturellement parce que mon
parcours au sein de l'assemblée
nationale m'avez démontré l'importance
qu'elle a dans les relations entre les
parlementaires et le gouvernement
je vais fait aussi je dirais comme élu
de terrain expérience que je partage
avec beaucoup d'entre vous mais aussi
comme professionnel droit en scène
avocat car je sais quelle est
l'importance
ce pour la crédibilité de l'action
publique
j'aime plus en maintes occasions
constater que les lois inutiles
affaiblissent les lois nécessaires
et quoi de plus inutile qu'une loi
inutilisés c'est à dire une loi qui ne
peut d'un point de vue juridique être
appliquée mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le gouvernement est
parfaitement conscient de ce problème
le premier ministre est en lui même
déploré lors de son discours de
politique générale je cite ces voies
bâclé qui ne sont jamais appliquées
on ne combat pas un effet d'inertie par
l'agitation tout particulièrement en
matière législative
à cet égard deux points me semble
important pour bien appréhender ce
phénomène inflationniste des textes de
loi s'agissant d'abord de la prolixité
du législateur national
je voudrais préciser que l'on ne vote
pas plus de loi aujourd'hui qu'autrefois
contrairement à une idée reçue
chaque année ce sont environ une
cinquantaine de textes qui sont adoptés
en revanche les nouvelles lois sont de
plus en plus longue puisque elle
comportait en moyenne une vingtaine
d'articles dans les années 90 contre
plus du double dans les années 2000
l'élément paradoxal de ce constat c'est
qu'en dépit de cette longueur croissante
nos lois ne paraissent pas suffisamment
précises pour éviter que le gouvernement
ou le juge ne dispose de marges
d'appréciation d'applications pardon et
d'interprétation nous lois sont donc à
la fois plus longue et moins précise
s'agissant de la productivité du
législateur européen
le gouvernement est à la fois totalement
engagé dans la poursuite de
l'intégration de nos systèmes de
régulation on vient de le voir dans le
domaine bancaire et en même temps très
attachés au respect du principe de
subsidiarité
il est toujours bon de s'interroger au
plan national comme au plan de l'union
sur le niveau pertinent d'édiction des
normes
juridique je sais que le ministère des
affaires européennes comme le sgg mène
avec le secrétariat général des affaires
européennes
une démarche parallèle à celle conduite
pour l'application des lois portant sur
la transposition des directives pour
laquelle la france est l'un des pays les
plus retardataires nous contraignant à
des transpositions massive par voie
d'ordonnancé monsieur lasvignes aura
sans doute l'occasion d'y revenir
il ya d'ailleurs des exercices
intéressant à cet égard qui ont été
menées lors de l'adoption récente de la
loi dite dadu 2012 mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de vous le dire on ne combat pas
l'inertie par la citation les exigences
du changement vous saurait se traduire
par l'adoption de textes en cascade non
évalués et mal rédigé la modernisation
de l'action publique est essentielle à
la construction d'un nouveau modèle
français alliant solidarité et
compétitivité
elle va de pair avec un objectif
exigeons celui du respect de nos
engagements de finances publiques
cette ambition nous oblige c'est bien
celle d'une nouvelle action publique
plus juste plus efficace et plus simples
dont la france a besoin
lors de la première réunion du comité
interministériel pour la modernisation
de l'action publique qui s'est tenue ce
matin même le premier ministre a arrêté
des mesures concrètes de simplification
des normes et des démarches
administratives ont été décidées qui
entreront en vigueur dès le début de
l'année 2013
le gouvernement de jean marc ayrault a
initié une méthode nouvelle
d'élaboration des politiques publiques
et les textes législatifs comme on l'a
vu lors de la conférence sociale ou
comme on le voit en matière de récidive
pénale avec la conférence de consensus
ce nouveau cadre de travail du
gouvernement ne serait toutefois
justifier un retard pris dans l'entrée
en vigueur des dispositions législatives
voté par le parlement en effet faire en
sorte que la loi s'applique rapidement
est une nécessité démocratique
disposition législative qui demeure
inappliquée met en cause la fiabilité et
l'efficacité de l'activité du
gouvernement ainsi que le respect dû à
la représentation nationale
c'est là un point important le président
de la république comme le premier
ministre ont eu l'occasion de rappeler
que le travail gouvernemental doit être
conduit en respectant pleinement le
contrôle exercé que vous exhorte le
contrôle que vous exercez sur notre
action afin de garantir au sujet de
droit une légitimité n'est pas dans une
légitime sécurité juridique
il est également indispensable que la
période qui sépare la publication de la
loi de l'intervention des mesures
réglementaires d'application soit limité
dans la tente de la parution des textes
réglementaires déterminer quel est le
droit applicable ne va pas sans
incertitudes parce qu'il peut être
délicat de distinguer parmi les
dispositions de la loi nouvelle
celles qui sont suffisamment précises
pour être immédiatement applicable est
celle qui ne pourront recevoir
application qu'après l'intervention ne
mesure réglementaire
il nous appartient c'est l'objet du sial
de corriger spurs ce comité de suivi
dirigée par le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement et le
secrétaire général du gouvernement est
composé de représentants des cabinets
ministériels et de l'ensemble des
correspondants ministériels chargés de
l'application des lois
une circulaire interministérielle a fixé
l'objectif consistant à prendre toutes
les mesures réglementaires nécessaires
dans un délai de six mois suivant la
publication de la loi
cet objectif doit être maintenu et sera
respectée pour votre parfaite
information sachez que le sial réunis en
deux formations le comité plénier avec
la co présidence du ministre et du sgg
avec des représentants de l'ensemble des
cabinets ministériels et des
correspondants d'application des lois au
sein des administrations centrales il se
réunit trois à quatre fois par an
en 2012 le comité plénier s'est réuni
les 26 juillet et 19 novembre dernier la
présence des membres des cabinets
ministériels aux côtés des
correspondants d'application des lois
permet d'échanger sur les éventuels
blocages politiques ou retard avéré
ensuite comité opérationnel présidé par
le sg avait la présence de membres de
mon cabinet qui assure le travail de
suivi technique des décisions prises
concomitants plaignait mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de nos travaux
il ressort notamment les points suivants
en ce qui concerne les mesures avec
entrée en vigueur différée auquel il
faut prendre garde
ainsi il y à 66 mesures qui entreront en
vigueur en 2013 dont 37 au 1er janvier
2013 et 28 en septembre 2013
les ministères de l'intérieur et de
l'écologie sont particulièrement
concernés le sénat a pu récemment
mobilisé à ce propos avec l'adoption
d'une ppl du président sueur relatives
aux juridictions de proximité
s'agissant de la question importante du
taux d'application des lois de la 13e
législature
celui ci est à ce jour 2 89 % environ
à ce propos je voudrais vous dire que
j'ai pris connaissance avec satisfaction
des éléments d'appréciation de votre
commission sur le rapport du président
assouline sur la loi du 5 mars 2009
relative à la communication
audiovisuelle
je vous indique que nous envisagerons
pour les dispositifs voter mais pour
lequel le gouvernement n'entend pas
prendre de mesures d'application les
mesures d'abrogation nécessaire une loi
d'abrogation des lois pour reprendre une
formulation du droit nord américain
pourra être envisagée le moment venu
à défaut d'autres vecteurs je pense que
je réponds très précisément à votre
question monsieur le président cette
préoccupation vianney qu avec la
décision numéro 16
du 6 maps et le comité qui s'est réuni
ce matin est relative à la limitation de
l'inflation normative une norme créé
doit s'accompagner d'une norme supprimés
c'est le principe qui a été rappelé par
le premier ministre ce matin
conformément aux orientations arrêtées
par le président de la république toutes
initiatives ministérielles conduisant à
la création de normes nouvelles devra
désormais s'accompagner de l'abrogation
d'un volume de normes équivalent pour ce
qui concerne à la présente législature
il est évidemment trop tôt pour évaluer
la situation mais il est bien évident
que les premières lois de la législature
nécessitant des mesures d'application
je pense notamment à celles relatives
aux emplois d'avenir trouveront à
s'appliquer dans leur plénitude sans
retard plus du tiers des décrets de
cette loi sont d'ores et déjà entrée en
vigueur
nous serons comptable de ce taux devant
le parlement sera informé régulièrement
un objectif de 100 % doit être visé à
cet égard pour la quatorzième
législature le taux peut être estimé à
ce jour à 38% mais il est naturellement
purement indicatif dans la mesure où le
délai de six mois est à peine entamé des
travaux du sial il ressort aussi
certains éléments qui seront autant de
pistes de réflexion que des changes avec
vous comme le parlement sera dans le
parlement sera être associé à ces
travaux tout d'abord la gestion des
procédures de rédaction puis de parution
des décrets comme des circulaires qui
n'est pas le point fort des ministères
malgré l'action déterminante du sgg à
cet égard il manque souvent l'influent
politique si j'ose dire
pour les responsables politiques ce qui
compte le plus souvent c'est l'adoption
d'une loi et non pas son application
pleine et entière
les consultations pour se pose aussi
divers problèmes
elles sont multiples et nous avons du
mal à en connaître l'intérêt exact un
très important travail d'identification
a été conduit et des décisions sont
prises
sur cette base des réflexions des
échanges pourront aussi être conduit
avec vous car il ne s'agit pas d'assurer
uniquement le service après vote à titre
prospectif
je trouverais fort utile par exemple
qu'une réflexion soit engagée s'agissant
de la formation des fonctionnaires
d'état qui participent à la rédaction
des textes d'application la qualité de
la formation des rédacteurs tout autant
que l'accélération des procédures de
contre st est une piste envisagée afin
d'améliorer la qualité comme la sévérité
des entrées en vigueur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs nous
sommes les interlocuteurs naturels de
votre commission et nous prendrons
connaissance avec intérêt de votre
prochain rapport annuel sur
l'application des lois se réunir et le
sial qu'on séance plénière au mois de
mai ce qui permettra de dresser un
premier bilan de la première année de la
législature
je souhaite naturellement que notre
collaboration soit la plus fructueuse au
service de l'efficacité de la loi est de
l'intérêt de nos concitoyens je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci monsieur le ministre il ya déjà là
des éléments de réponse aux questions
qu'on peut se poser mais tout de suite
je vais passer la parole à monsieur le
secrétaire général du gouvernement nous
avait très intéressé l'année dernière
c'était la première fois qu'on disait
autant de choses et pour certains même
vieux briscard on apprenait la façon
dont ça fonctionne et d'ailleurs et
pourrait peut-être pas pour monsieur
ollier m'avait passé une fiche quasi
confidentiel qui est l ensemble des
étapes que je suis un décret obligatoire
et il y avait très étape donc même quand
le gouvernement produit le décret il y a
quelque chose peut-être à simplifier
peut-être cette obligatoire mais ça ne
m'avait paru presque kafkaïen
7 cette histoire détresse validation
quand on a eu la chance d'avoir le
décret que la ville se poser dans merci
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
mon approche mon approche et techniques
mon approche est pratique et justement
au fil de cette occasion pour remercier
monsieur le ministre dit ajouté
l'influent politique parce que c'était
un exercice qu'on ne peut pas faire sans
un flux politique
je reviens peut-être quelques minutes
quelques secondes sur les changes que
nous avions eu justement le sait le 10
janvier dernier
j'y crois 2012 j'avais beaucoup parlé d'
éléments quantitatifs et je me souviens
que monsieur le président assouline
et puis le sénateur compte en barges pas
aussi à l'effet observé que c'était très
bien mais qu'il faudrait peut-être aussi
avoir une approche davantage qualitative
sur l'application des lois et que vous
aimeriez bien vous aimeriez bien
connaître quelques éléments qui soient
davantage de l'ordre de la qualité dans
l'application des lois nous avons
entrepris d'y réfléchir
il ya un premier aspect qui pourrait
aboutir assez facilement qui serait de
perfectionner nos indicateurs ces
indicateurs que l'on a dans le rapport
d'application malras 1 qui figurent un
excellent loi de finances perfectionner
nos indicateurs en ajoutant à ces
indicateurs quantitatifs un indicateur
de célérité je veux dire que l'on
pourrait déjà faire apparaître pour
chaque loi la partie des décrets qui est
prise à moins de six mois
la partie des décrets qui est prise de
six mois entre 6 mois et 12 mois c'est à
dire une période encore descente
et puis les décrets qui sont au-delà
c'est à dire s'il en existe qui s'en
prirent en plus de 12 mois mais on reste
à mi chemin entre le quantitatif et
qualitatif pour aller plus loin et
notamment vous aviez évoqué le fait que
finalement je m'étais un peu tous les
décrets à plat et que l'on savait pas
entre le décret très important et il le
décrit un peu accessoire qu'elle était
celui qui manquait donc je crois que
pour aller au delà sur ce point on peut
pas avoir une approche systématique
industriels
mais je me demandais si on pourrait pas
utiliser les rendez-vous qui sont
normalement prévues en application de la
loi de 2004 c'est-à-dire ce rapport que
d'affaires chaque ministère sur
l'application d'une loi au bout de six
mois
rapport dont je m'étais rendu compte
d'ailleurs qui s'était parfois ignorée
par les sénateurs eux mêmes parfois
toujours ignoré voilà ce rendez vous
pouvez me donner un prétexte pour me
rapprocher des ministères et faire un
point un peu plus qualitatifs sur les
lois - les plus emblématiques et ensuite
nous verrions comment le résultat de ces
échanges peut donner lieu à transmission
d'informations au parlement voilà ça
c'est donc un travail qui consisterait
en gros pour les lois au moins les plus
importantes à faire apparaître
premièrement si l'essentiel est fait et
deuxièmement s'il ya des points de
résistance aussi à des décrets qui
résistent qui va falloir qu'il va
falloir un peu plus de temps pour
prendre
j'en termine avec ce retour sur le passé
alors pour l'avenir monsieur le ministre
a dit a évoqué les traits de magna très
substantielle les orientations qui ont
été définis lors du comité
interministériel de ce matin je voudrais
si vous le permettez préciser un peu ce
que ça va ce à quoi ça va conduire en
pratique dans notre travail
d'application des lois
quatre points premier poids les
conditions d'élaboration des décrets
deuxième fois les conditions
d'évaluation troisième fois la façon
dont on peut simplifier et quatrième
point les efforts nouveau d'accès au
droit
sur le premier point conditions
d'élaboration des décrets alors c'est
vrai que les instructions qui nous sont
données par le président la république
par le premier ministre par le
gouvernement c'est de faire en sorte que
l'on maîtrise beaucoup mieux l'impact
des textes d'application des lois et en
particulier l'impact sur les
collectivités territoriales sur les
petites et moyennes entreprises sur les
entreprises de taille intermédiaire
alors
pour y parvenir nous allons
essentiellement engagés deux types
d'exercices premier exercice
on va s'efforcer de revivifier je dirais
les techniques de consultation monsieur
le ministre vous expliquer qu'on est en
train de supprimer un certain nombre de
commissions consultatives
vous savez que toutes les commissions ne
sont pas parfaitement vivaces
parfaitement moderne parfaitement un
éveil sur les risques la
surréglementation et ces aspects là il y
en a actuellement plus de 700 donc on va
commencer par supprimer sans ça c'est à
qui son commission va être supprimée
dans les semaines à venir c'est le
résultat du travail de préparation comme
l'a fait pour le comité interministériel
et puis on en aura un nouveau rendez
vous au ministère pour en supprimer
encore davantage et aussi pour arriver
dans chaque ministère et disposer d'une
véritable cartographie de la
consultation et aviaire au lieu d'avoir
une multiplicité savez en pratique
comment ça se passe c'est chaque
direction voir chaque bureau souvent en
titre et sa commission
ce qui est inadmissible et les
responsables du ministère ignore quels
sont les commissions qui sont dans leur
périmètre
quand on les a rencontrés
systématiquement avec le cabinet du
premier ministre
il découvrait en rayon de travail donc
voilà il faut organiser ça il faut avoir
une cartographie cohérente il faut le
cas échéant ont fusionné supprimés donc
ça c'est le travail qui nous attend pour
le prochain comité interministériel
c'est à dire dans quelques mois à côté
de cet effort de maîtrise des
commissions consultatives développer les
nouveaux modes de consultation c'est à
dire la consultation publique développer
la consultation publique
personnellement j'avais une idée que je
n'ai pas encore soumises au premier
ministre nous verrons si cette idée peut
prospérer
ça serait de rénover le journal officiel
c'est à dire d'avoir un journal officiel
qu'il soit non seulement un journal de
publication des textes adoptés mais qui
pourraient aussi avoir une partie comme
ça se fait au canada ou au québec qui
pourrait aussi avoir une partie
consacrée aux textes à l'état de projet
et qui pourrait ainsi servir de lieu de
rassemblement où l'on pourrait se rendre
pour connaître l'état de la
réglementation en projet à ce que l'un
des problèmes là aussi c'est le guen de
la dispersion c'est à dire
un certain nombre de ministères font des
efforts pour développer les
consultations publiques
mais c'est sur une multitude de sites
internet et donc les gens souvent
ignorent l'existence de ces
consultations
d'autre part pour enrichir ses
consultations publiques parce qu'on
commet une ne servent à rien il faut
donner des éléments à la consultation
est pour ça l'idée c'est autant que
possible de mettre en ligne le plus
grand nombre d'études d'impact sur les
décrets les plus importants alors c'est
l'autre aspect dans l'élaboration de la
norme enrichir les études d'impact
enrichir les études d'impact les rendre
compréhensibles aller au delà de l'étude
d'impact lorsque sont concernés
directement des entreprises en faisant
des tests c'est à dire on prend des
sorte d'échantillon d'entrepreneurs
concernés par la matière et on voit
comment ils réagissent à l'idée de la
nouvelle réglementation ont fait la même
chose on ferait la même chose pour les
projets de directives d'ailleurs si on
arrive à s'inscrire dans le temps
européen et ce travail pourrait se faire
d'ailleurs en association avec ce futur
commissariat la stratégie la prospective
dans le premier ministre a annoncé la
création savez qui serait une sorte d'
émanation du commissariat du plan à
l'issue de la procédure et sans la
ralentir outre mesure on aurait auprès
du secrétaire général du gouvernement un
certificateur c'est à dire un haut
fonctionnaire qui serait responsable de
vérifier pas que formellement la pause
mais la procédure était respecté ça n'a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt mais surtout que
le texte elle qui se présentent à l'air
d'un texte correct c'est à dire qui ne
surent règlement de pâtir de diot qui me
surprend ce rose voilà ça c'est l'aspect
élaboration et j'ai bien conscience
qu'il faudra le faire aller de pair avec
l'objectif qui est de ne pas ralentir la
publication des décrets d'application
des lois ce qui n'est pas une mince
affaire ce qui demande beaucoup
d'organisation et notamment qu'il vende
faire en sorte que les ministères cesse
d'avoir une approche exclusivement
séquentiel mais saches tuiles et des
procédures
deuxième aspect l'évaluation je crois
que la décision qui a été prise lors du
comité interministériel est très simple
et très clair les principaux textes de
loi seront évalués après quatre ans
d'application alors ensuite il faudra
s'organiser pour assurer cette
évaluation et cela pourrait être
notamment l'une des responsabilités de
ce commissariat la stratégie la
prospective dont je parlais à l'instant
troisième point la simplification
alors pour la simplification
nous allons faire des choses qui sont
des choses je dirais plutôt classique et
puis des choses un peu plus nouvelle un
travail avec le ministère sera fait pour
m pour élaborer des plans de
simplification mais ce sera un travail
interministériel je veux dire que les
ministères ne seront pas tous seuls face
à leurs responsabilités de manière à ce
que comment nous apprécions que le
travail de simplification porte bien sûr
des choses sensibles des choses qui
véritablement produisent des lourdeurs
produisent des difficultés sur les
administrés deuxièmement le premier
ministre donnera s'il doit l'avoir signé
aujourd'hui une émission spéciale à des
parlementaires pour la simplification
des normes relatives aux collectivités
territoriales troisièmement c'est un
aspect dont on parle peu souvent mais
auquel je voudrais m'intéressait de plus
près il y a le problème des circulaires
on a calculé on a fait on a fait une
estimation on a calculé que chaque
préfet reçoit dans l'année quatre-vingt
mille pages de circulaires 4000 pages de
circulaire qu'il est censé lire des
préfets m'expliquer que du coup il ne
lisez plus rien donc ça il faut y
arriver faut faire rire jaune
on a fait un premier pas c'est ce qui
nous a permis de présenter le premier
pas a été de centraliser d'essayer de
centraliser la circulation des
circulaires d'ailleurs savoir dans quel
point unique de ministères elle partait
maintenant il faut arriver à réguler le
flot des circulaires enfin
dernier sujet c'est cette démarche de
tradition davantage anglo saxon qui
évoqué monsieur le ministre à l'instant
c'est à dire une énorme créé une énorme
supprimèrent démarche qu'il faudra là
aussi harmoniser avec le souci
d'appliquer les lois et donc de préparer
des décrets avec des règles nouvelles le
quatrième aspects dont je voulais que je
voulais évoquer avec vous c'est les
questions qui tournent autour de l'accès
au droit accès au droit ça signifie
notamment ont continué le travail de
codification je sais que au sénat
beaucoup s'intéressent à ce travail de
codification
il ya notamment des codes qu'il faut
rénover et pas des moindres je pense
notamment au code électoral
il existe un projet il faudra arriver à
faire en sorte qu'ils deviennent une loi
mais ça n'est jamais très facile surtout
que la période n'est jamais la bonne
nous le savons et puis il ya aussi un
code de l'expropriation pour cause
d'utilité publique qui aussi en cause
d'importants je parle pas du code du
code des impôts dont on sait que ce
n'est pas un vrai code mais c'est encore
de réglementaires et d'autres exercices
de ce genre alors une chose que nous
voudrions faire qui est une chose
nouvelle et là aussi le premier ministre
nous a demandé de passer à l'acte
c'est le créer un code qui n'existe pas
qui serait un code des relations entre
l'administration et les usagers
simplement
alors je parle de relation entre
l'administration et les usagers hors
procédure contentieuse met donc en code
qui traiterait tous les sujets du type
adressé une demande à voir une décision
motivée savoir dans quel délai on
dispose d'une décision réfléchie une
décision explicite savoir comment on
peut avoir accès aux documents
administratifs etc
l'ensemble rassemblés dans son code et
précision peut être importante
là pour le coup ce ne serait pas un code
à droit constant mais ça serait un code
qui non seulement s'efforcerait de
rassembler les lois éparses mais
s'efforcera également de simplifier les
aspects les plus délicat des relations
entre administration et usagers voilà
l'ensemble de ces chantiers seraient
donc coordonné par
aux fonctionnaires qui pourrait
s'appeler commissaire général à la
simplification mais les titres n'ont pas
beaucoup d'importance ce qui importe
c'est la matière et qui donc m'assister
et dans ses travaux merci beaucoup
vous avez très utilement compléter ce
qui nous a été dit par monsieur le
ministre sur le plan très très concret
et plus technique jeu avant de passer la
parole à mes collègues il y a deux trois
questions ou d'abord il y en a une
où il peut y avoir une confusion
l'exécutif a besoin de contrôler
l'application des lois pour évaluer et
booster disons la mise en oeuvre des
décisions et nous aussi mais on est nous
ne sommes pas les mêmes c'est à dire que
nous contrôlons ce que vous faites
nous ne pouvons pas faire et donc avec
ce problème qui est récurrent et la
constitution notre commission n'est
qu'une amorce c'est pas la fin de
l'histoire
parce que le gouvernement et l'exécutif
a les moyens que vous venez presque de
de dévoiler gigantesque pour contrôler
les choses voire trop gigantesque si si
on peut faire quatre mille pages de
circulaire c'est qu'on a quelques moyens
on pourrait jamais donc et nous pour
contrôler on est quasiment obligé
d'utiliser vos moyens
ce qui n'est pas le cas du congrès mais
avec un parent de casser ses propres
moyens de contrôle et donc de se fier à
ce que vous nous donnez et en même temps
on doit vous contrôlez donc c'est un peu
compliqué tout ça donc il ya on a des
progrès à faire mais en même temps dans
notre méthode de travail avec ce que
vous annoncez ça peut nous faciliter les
choses notamment
dans lorsque vous annoncer par exemple
vous contrôlez le décret est ce qu'il va
s'appliquer
nous on a besoin de savoir si ces notes
volonté qui s'applique
c'est nous qui avons fait la loi donc si
c'est le gouver ça peut s'appliquer ou
s'écrire selon la volonté ou la lecture
qu'on a le gouvernement et donc nous
dans ce cas là notre objet est de
vérifier que c'est bien la volonté du
législateur qui s'applique et pas par le
décret quelque chose qui ont été
déformés en chemin et c'est là que
s'exerce la place spécifique du
parlement de contrôle donc là dessus
j'aimerais que l'on puisse avancer nous
avons posé des questions l'année
dernière notamment je redemande
instamment à ce que le rapporteur au
sénat d'un texte de loi puisse être
associé étroitement à l'écriture des
décrets je ne dis pas que c'est lui qui
écrit jeudi qu'il soit associé au moment
où les décrets d'application vont être
produits lui qui a suivi et qui est
porteur de l'esprit du législateur
puisse avoir le lien
le contact est très souvent les
rapporteurs nous disent que ce n'est
jamais le pain une fois qu'on a voté sa
part ils sont plus dans le coup
bien voilà c'est une étude demande sais
pas si si c'est possible facilement dans
tous les cas probablement au moins le
lien le contact la mise dans le coup
j'ai mis volontairement des expressions
très générale pour qu'on trouve quand
même quelque chose de mieux
qu'aujourd'hui
et puis il y à une autre question
en dehors de la publication des décrets
la loi prévoit souvent qu'ils aient des
rapports d'application soient remis au
parlement au terme d'un certain délai
vous avez donc dit que chaque ministère
au bout de six mois doit faire un
rapport on en a parlé l'année dernière
je crois le jeu alors peut-être que je
me trompe et que ces jus dans les
domaines qui sont proches des miens que
rien ne se passe mais je ne crois pas
disons que nous ayons eu depuis un an de
poser la question la remise de ces
rapports donc on se demande même s'il
existe des me dit qu'ils existent 372
donc voilà c'est à dire à peu près un
tiers
il ya un tiers donc là deux tiers de ces
rapporte ont été faits le parlement les
connaît toujours pas d'accord mais donc
ce sont des rapports de ministères sur
les lois les concernant loi qui sont
toutes passées au sénat et nous n'avons
pas connaissance de ces rapports et et
je dis pas seulement le rapporteur par
seulement la commission mais une
commission de contrôle d'application des
lois qui est là pour ça n'est même pas
n'a même pas la réception de ski et son
coeur de métier donc je pense que là
aussi il y a c'est facile d'y répondre
facilement vite plutôt parce que je ne
vois pas où est le sujet et vous avez eu
raison peut-être les questions viendront
on est très attentif très heureux même
là c'est la spécificité du sénat dite
jambes représentatives des collectivités
territoriales même si c'est ça peut
prêter à confusion de s'arrêter qu'à
casser des cas cette définition qu'il
n'est pas complètement sûrs mais en tous
les cas notre attention collectivités
territoriales fait qu on est très
heureux que le président et que vous
vous soyez tout de suite dans la
concrétisation est décidé de simplifier
les normes et surtout de prendre cette
décision que pour une norme
créée il ya eu de supprimer jeu je finis
par cette question
je crois que vous ai répondu mais
peut-être cg j'ai pas bien compris on
avait nous évaluer en remontant à très
loin c'est à dire depuis qu'il ya un
contrôle de l'application au sénat
c'est-à-dire 72 je crois 972 qu' il ya
des lois par exemple obsolète
est ce qu'un jour il y aura alors c'est
peut-être ça que vous m'avez dit tout à
l'heure
monsieur le ministre une loi qui abroge
toutes ces lois mais pour cela est ce
qu'il ya eu un travail de recensement
pour les abroger faut savoir il se
serait très intéressant mais très
bienvenus je le dis bien je le dis pas
seulement pour nous pour l'opinion
publique qui entend toujours on fait des
lois mais elle s'empilaient savaria qu'à
un moment donné il dit tiens il ya un
changement le législateur a fait le
ménage et ça serait un bon signe donné
sur le fait qu'on se soucie des textes
qui existent
je me suis je voudrais remercier bien
entendu monsieur le ministre et surtout
qu'il y aurait du gouvernement qu'on
n'avait pas trop l'habitude de voir dans
les enseignes parlementaire en vingt ans
de mandat de député je n'ai jamais vu
une seule fois un secrétariat du
gouvernement venir expliquer aux
parlementaires de la commission du web
notamment comment ça se passait donc ça
me paraît intéressant et c'est un peu la
justification de la commission dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui en ce
qui concerne les propositions de notre
président j'avoue que je suis assez
dubitatif
je suis très attaché à la séparation des
pouvoirs et je crois que le pouvoir
réglementaire
c'est le gouvernement donc
personnellement je répondrai toujours
non à une demande qui me sera faite par
un ministre et de participer à des
entretiens avant la confection de la loi
je pensais sa responsabilité
pas de compromis même avec la majorité
et je répondrais non sommes demande de
participer à l'élaboration d'un décret
par contre parce que le décrit soumis au
pouvoir judiciaire du conseil des
ministres a dit durant cette étape
par contre que les rapporteurs des
commissions et que les commissions
compétentes du sénat ou de l'assemblée
notamment soient régulièrement informé
de la façon dont les décrets
d'application des textes paraissent etc
ça ça me paraît important or ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui on voit notamment
de textes comme la loi hôpital patients
santé et territoires qui n'a pas encore
tout est écrit d'applications d'ailleurs
peut-être n'est-ce pas utile parce que
peut-être qu'on veut la mettre à leur
remettre en chantier peu importe mais ça
ça me paraît être une bonne chose par
contre participé comme le proposait
notre cher président assouline à
l'élaboration du dcri ça me semble quand
même vraiment personnellement je ne suis
pas très favorable
je pense qu'il faut laisser au
gouvernement la responsabilité de son
pouvoir réglementaire alors après bien
entendu si le décret n'est pas conforme
à la loi bain et il sera il fera l'objet
d'un recours
pas l'ombre d'un doute il ya un tas de
gens qui s'en charge c'est d'ailleurs
voilà mais par contre qu'on sera
régulièrement informé ça me semble être
une très bonne chose et notamment que
comme le fait david régulièrement vous
veniez devant nous dans cette commission
pour ferry tad la façon dont le
gouvernement envisage de mieux préparer
les textes c'est comme ça l'important
et puis on a oublié de parler de quelque
chose mais qui venait à la fin de ce
qu'a dit je crois le président c'est
quand même le travail de codification
parce que autant
bon une loi qui arrangerait toutes les
lois obsolètes oui pourquoi pas on
rigolerait je serais volontiers
rapporteur de tels textes mais par
contre on pourrait être mieux informés
peut-être et peut-être dans cette
commission du travail de la commission
de codification ce travail très
important et qui notamment codifie à
droit constant en principe mais aussi en
en supprimant ou en améliorant de choses
qui sont totalement dépassées voilà les
quelques réflexions que je voulais faire
mais je me félicite de l'existence de
cette commission notamment aujourd'hui
maire merci monsieur pierre michel
demain se soulever monsieur jean claude
lenoir et ensuite monsieur françois
trucy
oui merci monsieur le président je
rejoinds ailleurs l'appréciation portée
par notre collègue jean-pierre michel
sur la séparation des pouvoirs
en revanche il faut que nous soyons à
mesure de bien contrôler ce qui sort
après les lois c'est à dire anti
d'application je redis ce que j'avais
dit lors d'une précédente séance le
président je pense que le rapporteur
devrait jouer un rôle
le rapporteur connaît bien le texte de
la loi je crois que ce serait à lui de
vérifier pour le compte de sa commission
pour le compte de l'assemblée à laquelle
il appartient
la façon dont la loi est mise en oeuvre
et pas seulement les décrets
d'application également les circulaires
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire ici dans
la commission il ya des circulaires
rapport aux 88 pages qui ont été
rappelés par monsieur secrétaire général
c'est peu mais y en a quelques-unes qui
ont franchement
contredit la loi et l'esprit de la loi
no 6 la lettre de la loi donc que le
rapporteur qui connaît bien le dossier
puisse regarder cette presse un prêtre
est bien deuxième observation sur
président je vous rejoins tout à fait
vous disiez il serait bon temps en temps
de supprimer des lois obsolètes
je me rappelle que si tu nous rappelles
pardon que c'est et ce qui se passait au
cours des dernières années notre
collègue député jean luc warsmann
s'attelait tous les ans à la d'action
d'une proposition de loi et il faisait
supprimé 250 280 notre collègue vidalies
ces états sont malades de son c'était
ghosn est également sénat il se souvient
travail extraordinaire qui était fait
par le président warsmann le problème
c'est qu'il est tombé sur un os
ici au sénat et la majorité nouvelle
constituée à partir du 1er octobre
renvoyez l'exercice de jean luc warsmann
dans les abîmes profonde l'oubli en
disant non c'est une méthode qui ne
convient pas et d'ailleurs ajouté ton
sans donner de précisions et donc sans
argumenter c'est l'occasion de faire
adopter des dispositions nouvelles qui
franchement mon avis était tout à fait
faux finalement je vois monsieur le
président vous revenez à cette idée moi
j'ai joué beaucoup et donc on pourra
peut-être sollicité jean luc warsmann
qui par bonheur est sûrs députés même si
les plus friands la question des lois il
pourrait aussi contribuer à secondes et
l'intérêt que vous portez à cette idée
très bien le jeu c'est lui il peut y
avoir déjà une réponse c'est une
question peut se poser à moi non je ne
pense pas fait non non non non c'est un
propos des fins d'année c'est un propos
de scandales comme j'ai envie de rester
dans l'ambiance de travail constructif
vous accompagnez l'idée qu'il faut céder
quand même un truc il cela dit aussi
dans son intervention mais il peut vous
répondre sur les intentions maintenant
oui merci monsieur le président je
réponds dans les honneurs en reprenant
l'interpellation de monsieur le noir je
ne partage pas avec vous l'appréciation
que les propositions de loi de jean luc
warsmann soit toujours resté dans
l'objectif qu'elle s'était donnée et
c'est dommage c'est probablement pas sa
faute
j'ai été un témoin privilégié mais pour
pas parler dans le vide je vais vous
donner deux exemples
je ne suis pas sûr que de mettre dans
une ppl warsmann le texte qui
permettrait de remettre en cause l'arrêt
de la cour de cassation qui disait qu'en
cas de licenciement collectif il fallait
néanmoins l'accord individuel de
salariés du salarié lorsqu'on touche et
aux conditions substantielle du contrat
de travail
c'était autre chose que de la
simplification et ce genre d initiative
qui fait que c'est ce type de loi a
servi a servi de vecteur non plus à des
simplifications mais a finalement au
fonds d'aidé des vecteurs à tout faire
un peu de choses qu'on savait pas trop
où mettre on voyait bien qu'elles sont
arrivées là dedans je vais vous donner
un autre exemple mais il y en a à foison
parce qu'il était un jeu suivi
attentivement qu'on parlementaires ces
questions là est ce que je regrette
d'ailleurs mais par exemple le texte qui
sur la simplification du droit venait à
modifier les dispositions sur elle et
compte des conséquences de la découverte
de travail illégal sur les marchés
publics
c'était quand même rien elle savait
d'ailleurs généré des très grands débats
et je dois dire que là le summum a été
atteint à la fin de la législature mais
là le contexte était différent et je
crois que a été utilisée tout à l'heure
par le président d'autres circonstances
en référence à d'autres circonstances le
terme de kafkaïen mais je dois dire que
j'ai vu beaucoup de compassion pour
monsieur blanc qui était le rapporteur
du texte à l'assemblée pour avoir vu ce
qu'ils avaient dû supporter dans la
dernière loi de simplification ou en
réalité on a vu arriver toutes les
propositions de lois rentrée depuis le
début de la législature et qu'il n'avait
pu c'est plus être portés par leurs
auteurs et donc on a passé deux nuits
entières avec des amendements et qui
faisait chacun 15 pages et qui était la
loi sur les mobile homes dans les
campings sauvages la loi et je le dis
avec beaucoup de regrets parce que le
travail de début et là je rejoins votre
le début de votre intervention
ce travail est nécessaire et jean luc
warsmann a fait un travail très utile et
je suis de ceux je lui dit qu'il
regrettait que d'une certaine façon ce
travail était un peu perverti puisque il
a servi d'utilisation à des démarches
qui ne s'inscrivaient pas forcément dans
les objectifs d'origine ça n'en laisse
pas ça n'enlève pas ses mérites et je
crois qu'il a d'ailleurs fait beaucoup
car il a beaucoup par roger grâce à lui
et puisqu'il ya pratiquement eu je crois
4 loi de simplification au cours de la
législature
il en reste à faire ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est que tous nous
travaillons et nous réfléchissons a
effectivement pour répondre vous même et
au président une loi une loi
d'abrogation qui serait pas simplement
une loi d'abrogation des dispositions
désuète
on a commencé le travail de repérage
l'aïd et jean luc warsmann n'avait plus
tout embrasser mais l'interdiction du
pantalon pour les femmes figurent
toujours dans notre ordre juridique
je pense qu'il serait peut-être temps de
l'en supprimer
mais il ya aussi et c'est plus important
parce qu'il ya un contenu politique mais
il nous faut il nous faut un
il nous faut un
support juridique il ya des loi
d'abrogation vous n'ignorez pas que
cette majorité souhaite abroger purement
et simplement sans les remplacer pas
rien un certain nombre de dispositions
sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord mais nous souhaitons les
modifier et supprimer purement et
simplement
par exemple sur la rétention de sûreté
c'est un dispositif où il n'y a rien on
veut rien mettre à la place on veut
l'abroger purement et simplement
et donc il ya la fois des textes qui
doivent être abrogés purement et
simplement et des textes sur lesquels le
gouvernement actuel n'entend pas prendre
les décrets d'application sur des lois
anciennement anciennement voter tout ce
travail il est fait un peu en amont
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya une question
de la qualification vous dois la réponse
aux au parlementaire est donc l'une des
idées mais ne la prenait pas pour argent
comptant mais au stade où on est c'est
peut-être si le président de la
république et le premier ministre sont
d'accord au fond de trouver ce sera
différent de ce que faisait warsmann
mais essayer de trouver au fond une loi
qui se diraient pas de simplification
mais j'ai envie de dire d'abrogation et
qui abrogerait les dispositifs soit pour
des dispositifs qui sont obsolètes ou
désuets soit parce qu'il ya la volonté
d'avoir de l'abrogation mais le la ligne
commune à ces dispositions seraient
simplement qu'elle serait remplacée par
rien donc on ferait un texte
d'abrogation qui en ce sens s'inscrirait
dans une démarche de simplification donc
voilà je pense que votre intervention
était intéressante et je vous dis donc
dans quel sens on le on avance votre
président a ouvert un débat qui est qui
et pas qui est pas une petite affaire je
rejoins ce que dit ce que dit jean
pierre michel d'abord monsieur le
président vous dites que lorsque vous
devez nous contrôler vous n'avez que les
moyens qu'on met à votre disposition
pour contrôler c'est vrai mais voilà
le contrôle du contrôleur c'est quand
même une question qui ne tient
évidemment souvent d'une grande d'une
grande complexité
les objections de nature juridique voire
constitutionnel qui ont été avancées par
jean-pierre michel ne peuvent pas être
ignorées la séparation des pouvoirs la
hiérarchie des normes sepa
c'est naturellement dans le débat moi
j'ai une double interrogation par
rapport à ça est ce qu'on fait est ce
que vous faites
pardon des semaines de contrôler
l'utilisation optimale au regard de la
question que vous vous posez
il ya beaucoup d'auditions de ministres
de sujets sur lesquels pendant les
semaines de contrôle au sénat à
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement
est invité à venir participer à un débat
sur tel ou tel sujet mais le contenu le
fond des choses est important mais une
existence de votre commission notre
débat de cette fin d'après midi montre
que la manière de les appliquer tout
aussi important donc il me semble à
priori et dans tous les cas jour le
débat que c'est probablement par une
approche un peu différente qui
consacrerait entend de semaine de
contrôle à ces questions là c'est à dire
non pas quelle est votre politique pour
l'avenir mais qu'est ce que vous avez
fait des lois qui aurait été voté par le
parlement où on a là me semble-t-il un
rendez vous qui peut être qui peut être
tout à fait efficace dans la mesure où
pendant ces semaines de contrôle vous
êtes vous pouvez être interpellant sur
ces questions là et que le gouvernement
doit être là pour vous répondre
y compris avec tous les moyens
administratifs dont il dispose je pense
qu'il ya là un rendez vous qui pourrait
être utilisé ça encore modifie beaucoup
à nos habitudes et qu'on tombe pas dans
des observations qui pourrait être d
observation de la nature juridique assez
c'est compliqué
quant au travail de la commission de
codification je dois dire que
je lui rends hommage approfondie pour
avoir été comme beaucoup de jeunes
arrivant à la commission des lois à
l'assemblée nationale sans savoir de
quoi il s'agissait
décide désigné pour avoir l'honneur de
siéger à cette commission où j'ai
rencontré le doyen gélard qui était là
depuis très longtemps
il m'a accueilli il ya très longtemps
aussi maintenant avec un air gourmand au
bout de quelques jours j'ai compris de
quoi il s'agit c'est par le travail
juridique la complexité de ce travail
est tout à fait considérable et les
fonctionnaires qui le font méritent
notre reconnaissance et effectivement
extrêmement difficile de ce point de vue
là je tourne là un sentiment personnel
même s'il ya des êtres d'exception par
définition dans les parlements
je dois dire que la la la difficulté du
travail juridique à ce niveau là mais
quand même extrêmement compliqué pour
être suivie par un parlementaire qui
représente au telle ou telle assemblée
il n'ya plus su tirer la nécessité
d'avoir un compte rendu du travail de
codification en lui-même que que d'être
fait vraiment des acteurs ou alors il
faudrait imaginer totalement autre chose
je ne parle pas ici au nom du
gouvernement c'est une appréciation du
gouvernement que je vous donne mais
plutôt une expérience passée mais
montanes
les personnels que je veux je veux bien
partager avec vous sur sur sept sur sept
commissions voilà monsieur le président
ce que je souhaitais répondent aux
questions pertinentes ils ont été posées
merci monsieur milices l'assaut on va
l'utiliser le temps qui passe et autant
finir tous ensemble
au lieu de répondre à chaque
intervention que ceux qui ont levé la
main posent leurs questions ont fait une
conclut généralement répondants j'ai
pour n'oublier personne
j'aime monsieur trucy g yves détraigne g
marc laménie inscrits est ce que j'ai
oublié quelqu'un qui a levé la main bon
très bien donc on à ces questions là et
puis le ministre et secrétaire général
d'ailleurs complètement peut répondre ça
va à vous monsieur trucy kramer ce
président d'abord merci d'avoir organisé
cette audition qui est très importante
qui se devait d'y se devait d'être et
mes premiers mots ça serait pour
complimenter le ministre et le
secrétaire général de tout ce qu'ils ont
dit
d'abord ça prouve une chose c'est que
visiblement l'exécutif pense l'exécutent
l'exécution de la loi et son contrôle
très à coeur très au sérieux et que les
initiatives du sénat ne sont pas
étrangers à tout ça en vous écoutant
monsieur le secrétaire général j'ai été
quand même super fait admiratif d'abord
un peu atterré après de voir
l'importance que l'exécutif mettez à
faire toutes les fonctions de ce
contrôle de cette application tous les
dispositifs qu'il fallait prendre toutes
ses précautions qu'il fallait prendre et
à un moment donné je me suis dit mais je
suis agréablement surpris par cette
motivation mais alors à ce moment là on
se peut se demander quel est le poids
des conclusion du travail d'une
commission comme la nôtre ici puisque de
toute façon
l'exécutif a pris c'est cette initiative
d'une manière totale et on peut même
aller plus loin dans le dans
l'inquiétude c'est de dire si l'exécutif
ne se satisfait pas des conclusions de
la commission qui est la nôtre si elle
cela ne lui convient pas aussi qu'il
veut il envie de faire différemment ça
peut être très démotivant pour cette
commission il ya donc là une notion d'
équilibre entre ce qui se passe dans les
dans les chambres et ce qui se passe
dans les ministères qui à mon avis est
assez important d'autant que vous avez
même inquiété un moment donné en disant
qu'au fond dans l'est
le structurent l'analyser décret que
vous faites au fond pour savoir s'il ne
faut pas modifier et ça ça pose un vrai
problème pour nous parce qu'en
définitive si nous n'avons pas fait des
écrits nous ont fait la loi
les créneaux on peut espérer comme
disait notre ami michel qu'il respecte
la loi mais si demain des années après
quel que soit le gouvernement a par
rapport à un décret d'un gouvernement b
et via le modifier alors laquelle et le
respect de la loi initialement voté donc
s'il ya vraiment un problème pour nous
relativement important et puis je
terminerai par une alarme mal maximum
c'est que de tous sauf un sofina tension
n'a pas de tout ce que j'ai entendu à
l'instant j'ai vu ton ont travaillé sur
les décrets que la loi donnait et
l'hommage dans ma candeur naïve je
pensais qu'un travail comme celui que
fait la commission ici ou à l'assemblée
nationale je suis patient existe une
comparables c'était de dire si la
commission émet des critiques
importantes sérieuse fondée sur tel ou
tel aspect des textes précédents
peut-elle à s'attendre à ce que
contiennent on qu'on prenne en compte
par un décret nouveau ce qu'elle a
souhaité la commission ne se contente
pas d'analyser ce qui se passe pour le
critiquer ou pour le bronze s'en
satisfaire elle a aussi de temps en
temps il me semble sur le président est
là elle a suggéré elle a indiqué qu'elle
qu'il y avait des recherches à faire
dans ce domaine
au fond si on veut corriger la loi
qu'est-ce qu'il faut prendre comme
mesures pour y parvenir
voilà le mes réflexions je prends je
vous demande de penser qu'elles ne sont
pas volontairement désagréable merci on
n'en doute pas il détraigne oui merci
monsieur le président à mon tour aussi
de remercier le ministre et le
secrétaire général du gouvernement pour
les informations très intéressantes qui
nous
j'en donnais c'est plus une réflexion
que des questions que je voudrais vous
vous livrez
j'ai écouté attentivement les pistes
ouvertes par le secrétaire général du
gouvernement notamment l'idée de faire
des études d'impact sur les décrets ou
celle de d'établir un code des relations
avec les usagers
je trouve que ce sont de bonnes idées à
priori sauf que je me demande si on va
pas recréer de la lenteur de la
complexité de la bureaucratie faire des
études d'impact sur les décrets est-ce
que c'est pas contradictoire avec
l'objectif indiqué par le ministre de
sortir les décrets dans l'est dans les
six mois je crois que c'est ça vous avez
dit mme masoomi je crains je crains
aussi faire un code des relations avec
les usagers
mon dieu on codifie déjà tellement de
choses est-ce qu'il fallait aussi
codifié ce qu'il faut aussi codifié les
relations des usagers avec
l'administration dans l'impression que
tout doit être encadrée c'est une
vieille j'ai une tradition française de
vouloir marquer dans le marbre
beaucoup de choses mais là on a
l'impression que s'arrêtent les moindres
faits et gestes de nos concitoyens qui
vont être encadrés je trouve qu'il faut
y réfléchir à deux fois avant de se
lancer dans cette opération parce que
comme on dit avec une expression
populaire le remède pourrait être pire
que le mal et je voudrais l'illustré au
travers de la circulaire donc nous
savons tous que la loi ou le règlement
pour les services extérieurs de l'état
ça n'est pas la loi ou décret ou
l'arrêté ministériel c'est la circulaire
on le ceux d'entre nous qui qui ont eu
des fonctions exécutives dans leur
département le savent la référence pour
un préfet ou un ddt ou otc la circulaire
est temps qu'il a pas de circulaire il
n'est pas en mesure de répondre ce comme
ça dans mon département je pense que
c'est la même chose ailleurs n'est pas
en mesure de répondre aux demandes de
précisions ou d'éclaircissement concours
lui transmet et on assiste aujourd'hui
avec ses 80 mille pages c'est le chiffre
que vous avez donnée de deux circulaires
qui sont envoyées chaque année au préfet
a en fait 1 1 le mot est un peu fort je
veux dire dévoiement adea détournement
du rôle de la circulaire la circulaire
elle est le ministre de ceux ci à
monsieur le préfet elle est là pour
éclairer le préfet mais les tellement
touffue que le préfet aujourd'hui en
tout cas c'est ce que je vois dans mon
département depuis plusieurs mois le
préfet ou ses services ne font plus le
tri à l'intérieur de la masse
d'informations contenues dans la
circulaire entre ce qui le concerne lui
dans son pouvoir de contrôleur est ce
qui concerne directement la collectivité
le maire ou je ne sais quel organisme
qui est chargé sur le terrain de mettre
en oeuvre telle mesure législative si
bien que l'on reçoit maintenant le in
extenso
depuis nos préfectures les circulaires
que les ministres ont envoyé au préfet
et à nous
de nous débrouiller avec tout ça pour
dire ah oui ça ça me concerne ça ça me
concerne pas parfois on va recevoir 20
pages il ya deux pages qui nous concerne
selon le cas de figure donc si bien que
là là on est vraiment dans le cas de
figure où la volonté de bien faire est
totalement détournées de l'intention
première et vient compliquer et crée de
l'insécurité juridique alors qu'elle est
là pour clarifier et assurer la sécurité
juridique voilà je dis je vous livre ce
témoignage je pense que plusieurs
collègues pourrait dire la même chose
jouer ce témoignage pour vous dire que
l'enfer est pavé de bonnes intentions et
que à force de vouloir tout encadré tout
vérifié tout contrôler on complique on
paralyse plus qu'on ne simpliste merci
et puis dernière question intervention
de monsieur marc la mairie
oui merci beaucoup mesure le le
président anjorin souci aussi aux propos
de mes collègues pour ou 6e levée gérer
les interventions de monsieur le
ministre secrétaire général du
gouvernement parce que c'est vrai c'est
secrétaire général du gouvernement
nous connaissons moins même si j'irai
beaucoup aussi de de travail de l'ombre
sur tout et et mais pour nous j'irai on
dit on apprend tous les jours et et cet
après midi c'est particulièrement
formateurs dont je vous remercie
sincèrement
ainsi que monsieur le président pour
cette initiative alors bon il ya
plusieurs choses qui qui m'interpelle
parce que j'irai les lois j'irai le
mérite revient surtout à mes collègues
de la commission nos collègues de la
commission des lois
et c'est toujours aussi avec le binôme
dans l'ensemble des les administrateurs
des services parce que je crois que
c'est aussi ce travail je dirais qui est
très important de complémentarité alors
concernant la complexité est le nombre
de codes
c'est vrai que une loi dès qu'une loi
est examiné étudié en commission après
passe devant le sénat a enfin les deux
assemblées
après je dirais c'est pour modifier tel
article ou plusieurs articles de pas
référence à un code en moi je serais
incapable de dire combien il ya de code
mais il ya des codes pour je ne suis ici
que depuis 2007
élu depuis 2007 au sénat mais je
n'imaginais pas le nombre de codes qui
pouvaient exister en compte de la
sécurité sociale code de la famille code
général des impôts de collectivités
territoriales le code de l'urbanisme ou
le code même le code de la route tu
prononces code de la route parce que si
on l'appliqué chacun d'entre nous
l'appliquent mais moi je n'imaginais pas
honnêtement le nombre de codes qui peut
exister et je pourrais pas dire le
nombre donc donc c'est cet après pour
cette interprétation
je dirais modification d'un d'une loi
alors on prend qu'une loi mais on voit
le nombre
c'est le ministre secrétaire général
vous avez rappelé le nombre de lois
votées
annie annuellement alors à près de
l'autre côté c'est l'application alors
secrétaire général j'ai tout à fait dans
votre sens quand vous avez dit je dirais
le problème de beaucoup il ya trop
d'informations et moi ne nous ont
malheureusement on le vit au quotidien
et c'est de pire en pire je crois que
les nouvelles techniques de
communication on est inondé de mails
même d'une malheureuse comme une petite
commune alors là n'en parlons pas j'irai
en rond on a est trop d'information tué
l'information et un moment donné après
on est dans une société où même dans les
services et dans les administrations
d'état ou de collectivités territoriales
même les
les fonctionnaires les les serviteurs
qui font aussi leur travail avec
beaucoup de professionnels beaucoup de
passion 10 à un moment donné agir et il
ya même un cloisonnement dans les
services un manque de communication dans
les services sur le terrain et autres et
après belle implication
la répercussion pour les usagers aussi
au quotidien et ce manque donc on
déborde trop beaucoup trop
d'informations et après de complexité on
reçoit des tas de papiers et même si
j'irai avec mes collègues
même nous nous nous sénateurs vos jolies
aussi comme sénateur de base et puis
maires de petites communes ou autre
j'irai même si même en travaillant en
koni consacrant beaucoup de temps mais à
un moment donné on est on est dépassé il
faut le dire je crois un moment donné et
à un moment donné après quand je dirais
les 80000 circulaire bon après les les
représentants de l'état aux préfets
sous-préfets l'application des services
aussi qu'ils font à un moment donné on
n'arrive plus du tout à suivre parce que
je dirais alors vous avez cité jean luc
warsmann puisque ça de mes collègues du
département des ardennes que je connais
bien
il essayait aussi de 2,26 attelé mais à
un moment donné même avec la bonne
volonté qu'on peut avoir ben je crois
que
je dirais on voit réellement nous nous
limitons nous limite que je crois que
c'est le système qui est qui est comme
ça et pour le faire évoluer
c'est réellement pas simple je le dis en
termes alors après la simplification le
dis toujours mais après si je prends
l'exemple de nos trois fonctions
publiques état territoriale et fonction
publique hospitalière bas et j'irai où
je prends moi déjà la complexité après
les personnels une commune compte là un
agent même à temps partiel alors qu'on
voit pour changer d'échelon de grade
alors on fait référence à une loi la loi
du 26 janvier 1984 on cite toujours on
la cite puis après avec les d'autres
notre application d'une circulaire et
août alors qu'on veut la lourdeur alors
mêmes
il faut même une délibération pour une
petite chose prendre une délibération
pour changer même alors bon après les
perspectives de carrière bon alors une
valeureuse commune bron la très peu de
services très très peu de monde
bon après quand c'est des grosses
collectivités une grande ville ou ou un
conseil général
bon bah là il ya des services
spécialisés que les personnes ils
iraient peuvent se consacrer après
l'application pour ça se fasse dans les
règles de l'art mais après je veux dit
faut réellement beaucoup de mérite
beaucoup de courage beaucoup de
dévouement
et puis après l'application sur le
terrain puis après pour l'usagé même
nous qu'on se dit un peu avertis mais
c'est pas simple voilà je vous remercie
écoutez merci c'est presque la détresse
du sénateur de base qui vient de
s'exprimer mais il faut entendre tout ça
parce que c'est effectivement sur le
terrain
ce à quoi vous êtes confrontés beaucoup
d'autres élus locaux jeu
le ministre va conclure avec le
secrétaire général s'ils le souhaitent
je voulais lever une ambiguïté sur le
débat gay j'ai soulevé il faut vraiment
que que les pouvoirs soient séparés et
quand je demande que les rapporteurs
parce qu'ils se plaignent parce qu'ils
l'ont dit il le répète sans arrêt donc
je me fait aussi l'écho de cela qu'ils
ne savent plus une fois que la loi est
votée ce qui se passe derrière c'est pas
eux qui vont écrire le décret mais qu'il
y ait un système d'information et
notamment ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure qu'au bout de six mois ces
rapports des ministres puisse nous
arriver ou remportera cette commission
président de la commission on les fait
connaître c'est déjà dix ans le minimum
et et je leur demande parce que je pense
que là il ya aucun effort d'autre à
faire que de les adresser au moins pour
les deux tiers qui ont été réalisés
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
sénatoriale d'application des lois si
vous souhaitez revoir cette audition
elle est disponible sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très belle
soirée à tous